chaque premier jour du mois représente
un immense triste pour Marie
leblanca et demi lui coûte 795 dollars
par mois un loyer en dessous de la
moyenne provinciale mais quand même le
paiement sur logement gruge 62 % de ses
revenus puis je pense que j'ai soit
63% de mon salaire qui est pris pour
payer mon loyer
quand je fais mon loyer
j'arrive à calculer avec la CF que j'ai
50 dollars par semaine
à 64 ans Marie Leblanc atteinte
d'aphasie et incapable de travailler
depuis une vingtaine d'années n'espère
qu'une chose trouver un logement plus
abordable pour vivre mieux et gâter ses
petits-enfants tu sais c'est comme dans
une corde réelle ce qui ramène à l'avant
plan la question du logement social et
abordable le besoin est immense alors si
le côté
politique regarde juste avec des
objectifs pour la durée de son mandat ça
marche pas il faut voir à long terme
jusqu'à 20 ans 30 ans alors que le coût
moyen d'un 4 et demi dépasse les 1500
dollars sur l'île de Montréal Québec en
tant que rigide je déposerai un projet
de loi qui vise à rétablir un meilleur
équilibre entre locataire et
propriétaire
les groupes communautaires réclament des
actions rapides tout le monde là
s'entend sur l'urgence de financer du
logement social et de nombreux résidents
eux doivent encore faire preuve
d'originalité pour joindre les deux
bouts ici Gabriel proud Radio-Canada
Montréal